electrophilic aromatic substitution is a
reaction that replaces one of the
hydrogen atoms on benzene with a group
before we show the arrow pushing
mechanism let's dive into the reaction
flask and see what's going on in there
when benzene and bromine are mixed
they'll move around in solution by
diffusion
sometimes bumping into each other but
these molecular collisions are not going
to be productive they won't cause a
reaction bromine is simply not powerful
enough not positive enough to make
benzene react with it however if we add
in an iron catalyst this can associate
with the bromine building a positive
charge on it now when benzene bumps into
this activated bromine species it can
react one of the double bonds become
shared in a new bond with bromine and
forms a carbo cation on benzene now one
of the bromine atoms can dissociate from
the iron complex leaving as BR - this
deprotonates the molecule neutralizes
the carbo cation and forms bromobenzene
now let's show this mechanism with
conventional arrow pushing benzene uses
its double bond to attack activated
bromine and the BR - that's displaced
forms a new bond with iron now the drive
for this compound to become aromatic
again is so great that we can show a
spontaneous deprotonation and just right
minus h plus under the arrow this
reaction is general so anytime benzene
encounters an electrophile that is
powerful enough it'll open up its double
bond attacking it we can then show the
electrons pushing back into the ring and
if we'd like and have an appropriate
conjugate base in solution we can use
that to do a de protonation this gives
us our substituted aromatic ring now
that we've looked at the general
electrophilic aromatic substitution
mechanism let's look at the possible
electrophiles that we can add to an
aromatic ring
we already saw the addition of bromine
and equivalence of co
can also be used to react benzene this
reaction is halogenation the nitronium
ion can react with benzene in the
nitration reaction this gives a nitro
derivative sulfonation of benzene can be
accomplished using sulfur trioxide in a
solution of sulfuric acid
the 'silly imai on shown here can also
be attacked by benzene this ion has
resonance with a carbo cation that makes
it more obvious how benzene will attack
the reaction results in the addition of
an acyl group to benzene and it's called
friedel-crafts isolation finally some
benzene derivatives can react with carbo
cations this reaction gives alkylated
derivatives and is called friedel-crafts
alkylation benzene is a relatively
stable molecule however when it
encounters a powerful enough electro
file it will undergo electrophilic
aromatic substitution we've also seen
the five major benzene derivatives that
we can form by reactions with different
electrophiles but we haven't yet looked
at how those electrophiles are made and
the conditions under which these
reactions occur we'll do that in a
specific lesson for each reaction thanks
for watching